[Musique]
bonjour à tous bienvenue au parlement
ravi de vous retrouver pour 30 minutes
d'actualité européenne dans cette
émission direction la galice en espagne
à ponte vedra
depuis des années la ville et sans
voiture pourquoi ce choix de la
municipalité et comment la population
vittel ce bannissement reportages et
débats à suivre mais d'abord l'actualité
échec dans la dernière ligne droite des
négociations sur le break site liste
noire des paradis fiscaux sommet union
européenne union africaine
antonio tajani président du parlement
européen ancien commissaire à
l'industrie et membre du ppe le parti
populaire européen est notre invité
rencontre merci d'accepter de nous
recevoir monsieur le président merci à
vous pour l'invitation et première chose
la commission européenne les copines le
sommet des ministres des finances vient
d'adopter une liste noire des paradis
fiscaux qui compte 17 pays
aucun de ceux qui n'a aucune ans qui ont
été cités dans les périodes ice peppers
ni est notamment malte l'île de jersey
guernesey ou encore les pays-bas est ce
que ce n'est pas une mascarade monsieur
le président cette liste
non moi je pense qu'il faut s'engager
contre les paradis fiscaux
parce que si nous voulons aider la
croissance de l'europe
il faut aussi aider soucier de l'argent
sont essayé de demander aux citoyens de
payer plus alors il faut le saisir dans
les paradis fiscaux
il faut faire payer dès le
les géants du web apple notamment en
irlande
pas seulement en irlande mais parce que
travailler en europe et bien et donc pas
dépasser travail sont en train d'étudier
l'identité culturelle européenne
moi je comprends bien la globalisation
mais il faut des riscle il pense aussi
qu'il faut commencer à les garder au
bitcoin parce qu'il faut voir c'est
l'essai virtuels exactement ce service
d'avoir aussi des boules et financières
devront faire des dommages que vous
allez passer mais est ce que quand on a
une concurrence intra-européenne avec
des pays de l'union européenne qui ne
sont pas sur les mêmes règles du jeu
est ce que ce n'est pas se tirer une
balle dans le pied bien sûr je pense
qu'il faut moi je suis contre tous les
paradis fiscaux
moi je suis vieux sujet suis pour
l'harmonisation fiscale oui non c'est à
dire de même avec pas donc vous n'auriez
pas fait cette liste vous si vous aviez
eu votre - c'est pas moi que je vais
faire baby ce jeudi je marque je crois
qu'il faudra voir une harmonisation
fiscale pour garantir la compétitivité
pour les entreprises de tous les pays
vous avez eu theresa may je crois
concernant l'accord qui a
malheureusement pas pu aboutir ces
derniers jours avec la commission
européenne
le point de blocage c'est le statut de
l'irlande notamment
est ce que pour aboutir en fait un
accord entre eux les européens et la
grande bretagne
il va falloir en passer par une
dislocation de l'union jack par une
dislocation de la grande bretagne
je ne sais pas maj pavé hier étaient les
amis et beaucoup de temps et
je pense qu'ils elles étaient plutôt
optimistes pour essayer de résoudre les
problèmes dans son pays avant les
conseillers européenne la semaine
prochaine
et moi je juge optimiste gse nous sommes
en frais de soutenir et offre
négociateurs qui est michel barnier j'ai
parlé avec lui aujourd'hui et réunion
présent pourtant que nous les soutenons
la semaine prochaine les parlements
européenne va voter un document sur le
blick site espère on espère l'ombre des
voter et
un bon résultat c'est à dire qui il est
d'accord et j'espère avant la fin de
cette semaine
les britanniques vont dire oui à l'union
européenne et parce qu'il faut aller de
l'avant on ne sont pas contre le royaume
uni nous défendons seulement les droits
de nos concitoyens nous défendons la
frontière entre l'irlande du nord et la
république d'irlande et nous voulons
aussi creux que les grains est là le
royaume uni et respecte les engagements
au niveau financier
je pense qu'ils sont à côté de la cour
on est à la frontière de l'accord à la
frontière de balgau le problème c'est
que il ya aussi un risque si jamais il
ya une frontière du coup physique qui
renaît de voir un conflit de nouveaux
renaître entre la république d'irlande
et l'irlande du nord moi j'espère que
madame est capable de les irlandais les
unionistes qui font partis de sa
coalition exactement mais après il
faudra décider après cet accord
qu'est-ce qu'elle selon le glacier entre
nous deux un accord de libre échange qui
serait peut-être sur le modèle de quoi
du ceta avec le canada où avec la dame
mais jeu mais il faut aller de l'avant
et européennes pas l'europe
on va coopérer au niveau des d autant
donc eux aussi ont besoin de l'europe
ainsi qu'en seulement nous que nous
avons besoin d'eux on peut qu'ils ont
besoin de noms dans le cadre de la
réforme de la zone euro la commission
européenne va faire des propositions des
propositions qui ne seront pas forcément
celles qui sont sur la table notamment
l'apport la proposition française
emmanuel macron a dès son arrivée au
pouvoir
demandez à ce qui est une zone euro
renforcées avec un budget propre avec un
ministre des finances permanent qu'est
ce que vous pensez de ces propositions
comment voyez-vous l'approfondissement
de la zone euro
je suis favorable à ce qui dit macron
map à tous ceux qui à 10 microns je
pense c'est une contribution au débat
sur l'avenir de l'europe des choses les
idées intelligentes
bien sûr il faudra forcer l'europe à
niveau politique je crois que c'est un
choc positif la décision d'avoir un
ministre des finances mais ça suffit pas
à voir mais ses finances comme je disais
il faudra voir aussi une harmonisation
fiscale parce que c'est nous avons un
ministre et finançait n'ya pas sans une
harmonisation fiscale c'est la bonne
cela veut dire une harmonisation fiscale
au sein de la zone euro à 19 et pas à 27
c veut dire que l'union européenne à
plusieurs mois je suis votre obligation
fiscale dans la zone euro vous n'êtes
pas favorables potentiellement à une
rente à plusieurs vitesses avion dès
lors je suis pas très fan je pense que
je suis pas contre si la france
l'allemagne l'italie et l'espagne vont
de l'avant et prendre la guide de
l'europe à prendre la guider l'europe
c'est pas la même chose qui est et
laisser les autres en dehors vendeurs
notamment les pays de l'est qui
exactement
nous avions peur au dialogue c'est pas
facile parce qu'ils sont préoccupés de
l'immigration du changement de l'élite
des européennes mais il faut discuter
avec eux il faut pas les laisser dans
son coin donc voilà c'est pas possible
avec la pologne il faut discuter avec
viktor orban il faut discuter avec tout
le monde y compris si l'on défend en
affirmant nos valeurs nos principes et
en défendant aussi les possibilités de
solidarité parce que moi j'ai pas aimé
ce qu'ils ont fait quand il ya eu le
problème de la localisation des réfugiés
et dans dix noms mais sait on peut pas
laisser trop de réfugiés d'ain italie ou
en grèce parce qu'il veut pas venir
un état libre et seulement devenir un
héros par là comme nous aurons zi dans
le passé et l'on grille la pologne ce
pays là quand il y avait les communismes
ils ont désiré exactement vous aurez le
regarder sur les robes blouses roses et
dès maintenant on se reçoit beaucoup
plus de ceux qui donnent à la vente
faudrait dans ce cas là activer
l'article 7 du traité
moi je suis pas je n'ai pas une vision
policière de la situation et je préfère
la politique il faut les convaincre il
faut bien expliquer qu'il faut être
solidaires mais vous les avez reçu
antonio tajani plusieurs fois ici viktor
orban béate un shido ils sont venus
devant jana
rires je parlais jeu il faudrait essayer
de le camp mais parce que cette fois ça
suffit pas seulement c'est pas une
question seulement formelle il faut
faire comprendre à tous les héros peine
que l'europe c'est une chance et
ensemble nous devons bâtir l'europe de
demain de la lampe de l'avenir et donc
il faut comprendre ce qui se passe là
bas bien sûr ils ont une frontière
externe et moi je pense qu'il faut les
aider pour séquencer la frontière à ce
terme je pense à la bulgarie et il y a
une
vraiment expédie mans de la garde des
frontières européennes
et à commencer à bulgari donc c'est un
bon message
dans certains pays il y a des doutes
mais mais il faut dialoguer il faut par
des haies il faut défendre l'unité
européenne c'est pas facile c'est un
moment clé
moi je pense que si nous sommes capables
de gagner ce défi et nous avons un très
bon à venir et si jamais vous n'y
arrivez pas et c'est à dire que comme
jean claude juncker le disait lorsqu'il
a pris son poste
c'est la commission la dernière chance
et la législature de la dernière chance
moi je suis italien je suis optimiste et
j'essaie toujours de gagner
jean-claude luxembourgeois avant
peut-être saison nous avons nous aurons
le soleil donc nous aide
vous revenez vous disiez tout à l'heure
d'un sommet union européenne union
africaine dont qui s'est tenue à abidjan
ces derniers jours beaucoup
d'associations beaucoup de gens pointe
la responsabilité l'union européenne
dans ce que devient l'afrique
aujourd'hui notamment en fait sur la
situation en libye
on voit des esclavages renaître on voit
la libye aujourd'hui dans un état
politique absolument désolant quelles
sont les propositions l'union européenne
pour venir en aide à la fois aux
migrants pour les sortir de cette
ornière et à la fois à l'italien de la
sonas une solution sera basse habilité
un les billards gouvernement stable
capable ont cédé contre le succès passe
dans ce pays parce que s'il y a
les passeurs qui ne sont pas s'ils sont
les biens d'autres pays qui essaie de
gagner sur l' esclavage et s'il ya un
gouvernement fort et cela n'est pas pour
demain
c'est le président du gouvernement fort
bien sûr mais bien sûr mais il faut
travailler pour cela aussi contre
l'esclavagé il faut donner des messages
il faut défendre il faut garantir la
liberté parce que c'est c'est important
les esclavages c'était inadmissible
formule en feront donc nous avons dû au
sida dans les sommets d abidjan clic et
c'est inacceptable il faut résoudre les
problèmes mais mais il faut résoudre
aussi les problèmes de l'immigration il
faut faire des investissements
voilà pourquoi j'insiste sur la
stratégie ça suffit pas dans les
réponses sur l'esclavagé
dans une danse joomeo donner réponse
contre l'immigration légale devenait fou
d'avoir des stratégies pour gagner ce
grand défi gars sont des filles et c'est
quoi alors la stratégie parce qu'il
faudrait que je mets un open pas d avec
les gens qu'il faut que qu'elle parle
d'une seule voix par la voie des
italiens des français des allemands des
espagnols et des britanniques veulent la
loi alors si fait des investissements
pas pour le gaspiller de l'argent à
droite à gauche mais pour essayer de
développer un réseau d'infrastructures
capables d'aider des développements de
la feuille que c'est il faut aussi aider
les jeunes africains des marionnettes et
moyens entrepreneurs et dans le même
temps défendre les droits de l'homme
c'est à dire l'éducation l'information
donc c'est une stratégie et moyen long
terme
mais ce qui n'est pas une forme de
cynisme c'est du moins ce que certaines
associations pointent à
conditionner l'aide au développement a
conditionné cette aide sur
l'infrastructure sur la nécessité
d'aider en fait légende en afrique à la
gestion de nos frontières extérieures à
la sécurisation des frontières et à
l'arrêt des migrations
mais c'est c'est la même chose on peut
allaiter démonisation si on va résoudre
le problème d'un flic parce qu'on peut
pas résoudre le problème d'élimination
ce n'est pas pas capable de résoudre le
problème de l'afrique parce que ça en
2050 nous ont 2 milliards et 500
millions d'africains qu'est-ce qu'il
faut faire s'il ya changement climatique
ce cheveu sport gt terrorisme guerre
qu'est ce qu'ils font ils vont quitter
leur pays personne ne le sait chez lui
si si la situation si et son fils ou sa
femme ou sa fille risque de mourir voilà
pourquoi il faut résoudre il faut
travailler pour le développement pour la
croissance de l'afrique
il faut faire des investissements
intelligents pas donner de l'argent
dictature il faut faire des
infrastructures il faut v et travailler
à un niveau diplomatie économique pour
la plus d'entreprises et essayer
transformer l'afrique et qui a un grand
potentiel humain dans une chance aussi
pour l'europe donc voilà et il faut
s'engager il faut avoir des idées papa
par le seulement pour le second sert de
même aimé repos pour voir ce que nous
pouvons faire dans les prochaines années
pour revenir et ce sera ma dernière
question sur la libye il y a eu une
tentative française d'emmanuel macron en
fait de faire venir donc les les camps
les chefs qui sont aujourd'hui en train
de se disputer ce pouvoir politique en
libye l'italie malheureusement n'a pas
été convié à ce mini-sommet est-ce que
c'est dommage
moi quand je les dis il faut que
l'europe s'engage s'il ya une
compétition la france l'italie
l'allemagne l'espagne le royaume-uni
tel n'a jamais nous avons jamais sur les
gens regardez ce qui s'est passé et
quand on n'a tué kadhafi
c'est un choses qui concernaient les les
britanniques les américains et français
contre les italiens on n'a pas changé d
un but pas des français il n'y a pas des
anglais il n'ya pas des américains
il y a les frères musulmans
le terrorisme nous avons eu une
situation c'était une règle absolument
incroyable il faut un incroyable qu'on
est encore donc selon vous en train
n'est pas prêt d'oublier je pense que
monsieur mac on aura bien compris
non merci en tout cas merci a répondu
voilà donc pour cet entretien enregistré
il y à quelques heures direction
maintenant la galice en espagne à ponte
vedra la voiture est banni une décision
prise il ya plusieurs années par la
municipalité une manière de lutter
contre la pollution et les
embouteillages nous en discuterons avec
karima delli qui m'a rejoint sur ce
plateau
mais tout d'abord c'est un reportage de
samia 2 scheer pierre chapron et laurent
ferret
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
au bord de l'atlantique la ville de
pontevedra s'étale autour du fleuve les
rays c'est l'une des premières dans la
région espagnole de galice a tenté de se
passer des voitures
[Musique]
chaque matin maria parcours 20 km pour
aller travailler à pontevedra
arrivés aux portes de la ville elle doit
descendre de son véhicule
car dans le centre les voitures ne sont
pas les bienvenus nous sommes dans un
parking public on peut se garer est
resté toute la journée toute la nuit
même c'est complètement gratuit d'une
dizaine de parkings comme celui ci
autour la ville le reste du chemin il
faut le faire à pied le premier jour où
j'ai fait ça quand je suis venu
travailler je me suis dit waouh c'est
horrible je ne vais pas y arriver
une semaine après je me suis rendu
compte que c'était bien mieux que ces
10-15 minutes de marche c'est finalement
le seul moment où je fais des exercices
la voiture n'est pas totalement banni du
centre
seuls les trajets indispensables sont
tolérés avec un stationnement limité à
10 minutes
aucune barrière à l'entrée le système
repose sur la confiance et le centre
historique
seuls ceux qui en ont besoin peuvent y
circuler ceux qui ont besoin d'un
service dans la zone piétonne
ceux qui vont chercher au livre à un
paquet dans un commerce ou récupérer une
personne en fait il faut avoir une bonne
raison pour pouvoir entrer dans le sang
reste de la ville la circulation est
libre mais le stationnement limité à 15
minutes
tout manquement à la règle est
sanctionné d'une amende de 100 euros
dallas face à des stars cette zone il y
à 400 ou 500 amende par an c'est un
chiffre très faible
les gens respectent la règle cette
politique a été mise en place par le
maire miguel angel fernandez
quand il est arrivé à la mairie en 1999
les 84 mille habitants de pontevedra
vivaient dans les embouteillages
permanents
on avait du bruit et des embouteillages
et bien sûr de la pollution des
accidents dans toute la ville et
personne appréciée ça les gens
quittaient la ville parce que l'espace
public n'était ni agréable ni habitable
dès son élection il est l'os et une
politique de grands travaux pour
piétonniser la ville
la plupart des routes sont devenues des
voies à sens unique limitée à 30 km
heure les trottoirs ont été élargis pour
rendre l'espace public aux piétons et
aux cyclistes comme henrique nous sommes
sur la place de peregrina avant c'était
un carrefour où passer des milliers de
voitures et maintenant il n'y en a
quasiment plus sauf quelques riverains
avant c'était un lieu pas très paisible
pas très sûr
maintenant il ya des enfants qui jouent
ici les ponte vedra se retrouve sur
cette place avant de sortir il ya
beaucoup de cyclistes qui ont l'habitude
de passer ici
d'après la mairie le trafic automobile a
diminué de 70% dans l'ensemble de la
ville de quoi réduire de moitié les
émissions de co2 à pontevedra
c'est perceptible surtout quand je
avant j'avais un peu d'irritation
dans la gorge
aujourd'hui ce n'est plus le cas
ponte vedra compte désormais onze
boutiques cycliste contre 2 auparavant
depuis la piétonnisation la mairie mise
sur le commerce local
elle n'autorise plus aucune construction
de grand centre commercial dans la ville
a parié sur les petits magasins de
proximité
on pense que c'est ce qu'il ya de mieux
les grandes surfaces pousse les gens à
prendre leur voiture
ça crée du trafic pour y aller pour
revenir et donc des embouteillages un
geste qui au départ n'a pas suffi à
calmer la colère des petits commerçants
ils redoutaient une baisse de la
clientèle mais les craintes se sont vite
apaisée quand ils y ont trouvé leurs
intérêts
les livraisons sont plus faciles et les
clients plus nombreux c'est plus commode
avant avec les embouteillages les gens
ne s'arrêtait pas c'était un endroit
inconfortable pour marcher
c'était vraiment petit avec des
trottoirs étroits qui étaient bondés et
les gens de s'arrêter là réparateur
d'après un sondage récent les habitants
de pontevedra réalise 90% de leurs
achats dans des commerces de proximité
ici la piétonnisation n'a pas seulement
permis de réduire le trafic
elle a surtout redynamiser un centre
ville qui se vider de ses habitants
[Musique]
alors pourrait-on imaginer demain une
ville sans voiture c'est la question que
j'ai posée donc à karima delli merci de
nous avoir rejoints vous êtes députée
européenne membre d'europe écologie les
verts et vous êtes surtout présidente de
la commission transports ici au
parlement
l'exemple de ponte vedra karima delli
est ce que c'est un exemple à suivre
ou est ce qu'on ne peut pas le dupliquer
dans des grandes villes là c'est une
ville moyenne d'à peu près 85 mille
habitants et a énormément aujourd'hui
deux îles qui prennent la décision de
faire en sorte que déjà leur centre
ville
on est plus de voitures on à oslo
bordeaux en france on a la rochelle
énormément de ville disent une chose il
est grand temps d'en terminer avec la
pollution de l'air est fait il faut que
les gens comprennent que la voiture
au départ c'était l'objet pour gagner du
temps et de la liberté aujourd'hui la
voiture c'est devenu le synonyme de
calvaire et de perte de temps surtout
quand on voit effectivement à quel point
notamment dans les grandes villes comme
paris
les temps de transport en fait sont
multipliées mais ça implique aussi et on
le voit bien dans le reportage bas
d'avoir des infrastructures qui
fonctionne au tour 1 ces parkings
gratuits à l'entrée des grandes villes
des transports potentiellement aussi
gratuite et qui fonctionne c'est à dire
que par exemple dans les grandes
agglomérations je pense à bruxelles qui
est également pétri d'embouteillage et
qui a des problèmes de transports ou à
paris est ce que c'est pas pour tout de
suite
de toute manière on n'aura pas le choix
pourquoi parce que 70% des émissions de
gaz à effet de serre sont dans les
villes
donc il va falloir prendre des mesures
assez rapide et pas radical parce que
les consommateurs et les citoyens
changent eux mêmes largement pro
comportement 60 % des parisiens n'ont
pas de voiture voilà à dos mais la
question c'est plutôt pour ceux qui
habitent autour de paris les
banlieusards par exemple on qui va
falloir demain trouver des ce système
allégé c'est à dire que la voiture
individuelle n'existera pas elle va de
plus en plus disparaître demain la
voiture sera partagée énormément
d'autopartage vont commencer à se
multiplier il faut renforcer ce qu'on
appelle la multimodalité
c'est à dire au sortir d'un train au
sortir d'un métro au sortir d'un bus on
doit être capable aussi d'avoir une
mobilité le bus faire le vélo faire en
sorte d'avoir des lieux pour pouvoir
marcher on a le retour de la marche qui
est très fort la priorité notamment en
france va être de miser sur la
rénovation de pariente de notre service
ferroviaire de faire en sorte que qu'on
réponde aussi aux précaires de la
mobilité on les compte environ a eu 7 8
millions en france c'est toutes les
personnes qui n'ont pas les moyens
d'utiliser les transports ou qui ne sont
pas desservies ça ça va être des grandes
priorités est ce que tu as une priorité
européenne vous au titre de votre
présidence de commissions ce que c'est
quelque chose que vous portez au sein de
la commission
alors c'est quelque chose que nous
portons avec trois objectifs parce qu'on
est en train de faire de la prospective
la mobilité de demain doit répondre à
trois objectifs
tout d'abord la moe l'idée sera bas
carbone c'est à dire il faut sortir du
diesel la pollution de l'air est
responsable de cinq cent mille morts
prématurées par an dont voir exemple
anne hidalgo qui dit on sort en fait du
diesel en 2024 en
à paris et l'essence en 2030 c'est pas
une lubie
c'est pas une lubie du bar c'est
possible c'est pas une lubie et d'autres
villes sont déjà en train de le faire
pékin est en train de le faire lorsqu'on
a la chine qui dit à partir de 2019
plus aucun aucune compagnie automobile
sortira des voitures avec des énergies
fossiles
il vomit ils vont être sur un mix
énergétique de l'électrique de
l'hydrogène et du tout ça il faut
anticiper donc demain la mobilité il
faut qu'elle soit bas carbone
on a aussi la coop 21 et donc des
engagements respectés alors que 30 % 1
30% c'est le le nombre que dépensent les
transports en termes de gaz à effet de
serre c'est le secteur qui explose c'est
incroyable parce que vous en parlez vous
même il ya des clans on votait l'accord
de paris pour maintenir en fait à
moindre degré l'augmentation fois le
réchauffement climatique on voit bien
qu'on n'y est pas le compte n'y est pas
et par ailleurs
on a pas en france tout du moins
l'écotaxe qui est quand même un projet
qui a été porté au niveau européen qui a
été un four complet et total alors vous
deviez vous même le problème c'est les
émissions notamment de particules à dire
que là le transport l'écotaxe qu'est ce
qu'on fait et ce qu'il faut la rétablir
mais on n'a pas le choix on va pas
l'appeler écotaxe pour la neva comment
on appellera l'eurovignette ce sera un
robinet trop lasse donc c'est le retour
de l'écotaxe par l'eurovignette hier
c'est par le parlement européen et le
parlement européen et surtout la
commission européenne
ensemble on décide de faire une vraie
fiscalité aux écolos partout en europe
pourquoi parce qu'il faut mettre en
place le principe pollueur payeur et il
faut une taxe poids lourds
parce que il faut aussi que ceux qui
utilisent la route et qui sont des très
gros pollueurs paix ou seulement ces
externalités dernière question karima
delli comment on finance tout ça il ya
plusieurs pistes d'abord il ya le
système de l'écotaxe ou le thym le poids
l'eurovignette comme voilà on
l'eurovignette les recettes on devrait
plus les accorder sur des projets
urbains durables et non sur des grands
projets comme le lyon turin comme notre
dame des landes où ça c'est le vieux
monde le nouveau monde c'est de la
mobilité d'oka les transports et les
transports du quotidien donc ça on une
part importante en termes de recettes
deuxième volet sur lequel on peut aussi
s'attacher c'est qu'au niveau européen
on a quand même le plan juncker le plan
hincker sur sa partie de progrès en
investissement
absent en avait vraiment les chais selon
vous sur ces questions là pour l'instant
dans le poème kayak et 8% pour les
transports demain il faut que ça passe à
30% pourquoi parce que c'est gagnant
pour les territoires en termes
d'attractivité
c'est gagnant en termes de création
d'emplois mais surtout c'est gagnant
pour la santé les gens parce qu'on doit
retrouver un air sain bah écoutez merci
en tout cas d'avoir été avec moi c'est
l'heure tout de suite du checkpoint jean
luc mélenchon leader de la france en
soumises vous n'avez pas pu la rater a
jeté un pavé dans la mare concernant le
drapeau européen
on s'en souvient tous selon lui c'est un
symbole religieux vrai ou faux
c'est le checkpoint et c'est guillaume
gilbert à la barre
[Musique]
les origines du drapeau européen le
parti de jean luc mélenchon la france
insoumise récemment déposé plusieurs
amendements visant à retirer le drapeau
européen de l'assemblée nationale
d'après eux ce drapeau est un emblème
religieux fait les douze étoiles qui a
autour dont je sais plus quelle chapelle
de la tête de la vierge parce que c'est
les douze apôtres pour ceux qui
connaissent pas c'est le pipe qui a
inventé le drapeau qu'il dit encore une
fois donc c'est un emblème religieux
voyons d'abord comment est né ce drapeau
remontons le temps jusqu'en 1955
à l'époque le conseil de l'europe se
cherche un emblème après cinq ans de
discussions les membres finissent par
s'accorder sur un cercle composé de
douze étoiles d'or sur fond azur
en 1985 il devient l'emblème officiel de
ce qui deviendra l'union européenne
officiellement les étoiles symbolise les
idéaux d'unité de solidarité et
d'harmonie entre les peuples d'europe
contrairement à une idée reçue le nombre
des toiles ne correspond pas au nombre
d'états membres dans la résolution
adoptée par le conseil de l'europe
on peut lire que le nombre 12 symbolise
la perfection et la plénitude
mais alors pourquoi jean luc mélenchon
parle d'un emblème religieux
il fait en fait référence à une
interview d'arsène heitz le peintre
strasbourgeois qui a dessiné le drapeau
européen en 1989
arsène eight explique s'être inspiré
d'une médaille à l'éffigie de la sainte
vierge
entouré de douze étoiles d'or si un
symbole chrétien inspiré le créateur du
drapeau la bannière européenne n'est pas
pour autant un emblème religieux
dans un ouvrage robert piché président
du comité en charge de la création de
l'emblème européen affirme avoir refusé
une proposition de drapeau orné d'une
croix
il y avait en effet au sein du conseil
de l'europe un peuple non chrétiens la
turquie et la plupart des socialistes
des divers pays d'europe et est hostile
à ce symbole on voit donc bien que lors
de sa création il y avait bien une
intention de ne pas véhiculer de
symbolique religieuse dans le drapeau
quand jean-luc mélenchon nous dit que le
drapeau européen est un emblème
religieux c'est plutôt faux et voilà
pour cette chaîne c'est la fin de cette
émission mais pas de panique on se
retrouve la semaine prochaine du moins
vous retrouverez ahmed tazir à
strasbourg très belle semaine à tous
ciao
[Musique]